well honestly we've been around for a
long time he's a top player and he's one
of the top players I faced him many
times in regular chess I first faced him
when he was think 15 years old stuff
I've been I've been playing him for for
a long time well versed is not a new
name for me I've played in many many
times well it's harder to prepare for
this tournament compared to a standard
tournament because usually you know it
plays a lot of accent on the openings on
the repression of your opponent and here
you don't really know the starting
position yes we have a special history
together and that's why I feel like Tim
because if a top player it's my best
players in the world and it's also very
gentlemanly and I'm not sure if we have
played the chess960 tournament before so
I think we're evenly matched in that
regard well I think Wesley just like me
is not a very stable blistering rapid
player I've also had my fair share of
good results and bad results as you
might have remembered I played very
badly in love and this year I played
very well last year I've just bitten
shirahama drf in an online blitz event
which is a which is a big confidence
boost for me because chakri R is one of
the world's best players
as well and wrap it in bliss so I'm not
too worried I mean occasionally Wesley
is playing a little dirty with his body
language and clog bank but I think we'll
be past that so this is gonna be fine
so I haven't done well my st. Louis
Tournament lately so I'm here and I'm
ready to bounce back
you